[موسيقى]
هذه واحدة من أكثر
عوامل الجذب ابتكارًا التي
أنشأناها ،
وأعتقد أنها جزء كبير حقًا من
السماح لضيوفنا بالشعور بأنهم
مشاركين نشيطين في القصة
بطريقة مختلفة تمامًا ،
فنحن نستخدم الوسائط التي نستخدمها  نحن نستخدم
نظارات ثلاثية الأبعاد ولكن لدينا أيضًا
مجموعات مادية ولذا فهي تعمل على محاولة جعل هذا
الشعور واقعيًا قدر الإمكان
لضيوفنا عندما يكونون في عربة مغني الويب ،
لذلك نحن في الواقع نحلل
حركات ضيوفنا
60 مرة في الثانية ، نحن قادرون على
تتبع إيماءات ضيوفنا عندما يكونون
على متن مركبة نبالة الويب
بحيث تشعر في الواقع وكأن
الشبكات تأتي من أذرعهم
مباشرة إلى الأهداف ،
نعلم أن ضيوفنا يحبون الكتب المصورة
إنهم يحبون الأفلام ، لذلك
أردنا إنشاء
مكان يمكنهم فيه أن يكونوا في الواقع حول
كل هؤلاء الأبطال الخارقين حيث يمكن أن
يشعروا أنهم كانوا في حركة
مع الأبطال